how's comrades nice pants holy [ __ ]
we're back oh you cannot be serious
what is wrong with my brain what I'm
welcoming back in oh my [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] it's not enough that I had to
replay the entire [ __ ] game okay
we're back
don't hate jump wow that sure was hard
what is going on there that looks tricky
man I'm not gonna touch them
don't jump and then we go here what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
don't you dare hit my having something
invisible I don't touch the grass I
don't trust anything jump it test you
told me to jump a polenta yeah my [ __ ]
make sense oh my hand at all if I
survive this and write postcards to my
grandma don't tell me grandma oh god
yeah once my ass yeah yeah that don't
jump yes yes but alright and now you
don't jump
[ __ ] your horse what kind of hole is how
are you anyway you just wanted to buy
them that sweet ass nice sweet eh yes
checkpoint oh that feels good what the
[ __ ] what fine I'll go this what what is
that
wait they Oh
oh I get it I barley makes it what now
what what does it say oops fail that's
funny that's so funny huh
alright I need to land on that [ __ ]
come here [ __ ]
there we go oh my god oh my god just why
would you why would you I would I were
like I want to cuss in Swedish that is
means I have to sub tunnel that [ __ ]
laters I'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ] slight
English - oh you had a mech thing
there we go and they would jump now can
you stop being a [ __ ] yes wart
yes [ __ ] yes yes - ah it's your nickel
time [ __ ] oh it's on Oh with on I'm a
I'm a I'm a I'm a I'm a mother but I
gotta come back come back
oh no you didn't do that [ __ ] but
bricked a comment oh boy time so go
right dad in fit that I don't understand
I don't understand this come hey you
know what if you could stay on the
platform that we [ __ ] amazing every
[ __ ] amazed yeah I hate everything
what do you want from me okay now or
never
what it's a fake one it's a [ __ ] one
it's the [ __ ] one but not money yes
[ __ ] yeah oh well this one oh yeah
did go gonna get that number what file
it all the way
dirty dirty dirty to touch which one did
it that's even worse than buying okay so
this time I will not like what the [ __ ]
what is this okay what if I jump on the
edges Mandy
that jump the edges yes oh my god it
worked
oh my god what are they oh my god not
another chase not another chase why the
[ __ ] is that who created that atrocious
oh my god it's the ugliest thing I have
ever seen after Miley sorry it is Miley
Cyrus Vance holy [ __ ] oh god yes yes yes
don't yeah you did yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh Jack London okay here we go here we
go here we go here we go well nothing
wrong with me [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that shitty
song never helps anyone oh god he's so
scary I don't like him mom I'm
tryharding my ass off right now
I did it on the first try almost it's
like come on one mistake that's how it
takes in my bed
[ __ ] see look at night oh my god oh my
god oh my god mom mom mom
what is he doing up there
he's haxing okay okay okay okay okay
okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's good oh that feels good oh
that feels good
oh that feels good okay act Oh - feel
skewer yeah
oh they @o they act it would actually
use good yeah what what come on I just
want to finish this page what I did it
holy [ __ ] it takes so many tries oh I
die at the dumbest part
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
what no [ __ ] you I don't know about that
ball name hungry [ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes
ah only 252 it FS huh I think go ahead
Anna like him you enjoyed his m4 us and
I'll see you in level throw these [ __ ]
it's gonna be epic bro fish bros see ya